[Music]  what tell me  tell me you saw the godzilla versus king  kong footage from ccxv tell me you saw  it no i've been waiting all day for it  the trailer's finally out  no man it's just two seconds two  seconds yeah but it's a pretty [ __ ]  sweet two seconds  it's pretty [ __ ] sweet what's the two  seconds the kong's like  roaring and then godzilla's like  swimming and congrats  do you like see them in the same shot at  least nope  people are doing videos on this yeah  yeah  yeah yeah what's there to talk about i  don't know man  but for sure channels like new rockstars  and emergency awesome they're going to  tell me like the 50 things i miss in  these two seconds and it's gonna be  sweet  why are you so excited why aren't you  huh  why aren't you we've been waiting five  years to get  footage and we finally have two more  seconds  to add on to the previous two seconds  that we got  just be grateful okay i didn't mean to  offend you i hate you  i hate you